here now with reaction the author of the
new book hears the deal former senior
counselor to president trump kellyanne
conway along with the author of
suppression deception snobbery and bias
fox news contributor ari fleischer all
right i'll start with you kellyanne you
know it is amazing when you look at uh
jeff bezos the millions that he gave to
joe biden the millions that he's made
during the biden administration for him
to take joe biden on in such a public
way
is really shocking in fact i think it
speaks to
his not just disillusionment but total
disappointment in this joe biden
president
it also judge speaks to the fact that so
many captains of industry like elon musk
jeff bezos and others some of the great
innovators of our time do not want to be
held responsible and accountable for
what this president says and does so if
they don't respond they're somewhat
complicit in their silence silence
becomes acquiescence in agreement but it
also was quite striking to see a tweet
by the oil and gas association in
response to president biden's tweet they
said hey i hope whatever white house
intern wrote that tweet will take an
economics 101 course when he or she gets
to college that's not just meant to be
sarcastic that means to be substantive
that it was so off the mark that even
jeff bezos who by the way has other
things to do
felt the need to clap back at the
president um look i don't think it's a
fair fight in anyone's eyes if joe biden
who has a 36 approval rating down from
54 down 50 to 54
from a year ago when he took office i
don't think it's a fair fight for joe
biden to go up against an elon musk or
jeff bezos these guys are
multi-billionaires who have created so
many jobs so much wealth and the like
and they're not just not going to win
that debate look 10 of the country said
we're heading the right direction that's
because of gas prices and inflation all
right ari i'll ask you this you know
blaming the mom and pop gas stations
that have to make money by selling
cigarettes and candy bars and i haven't
met anyone who's an owner of those
companies you know who is a really
wealthy guy or a woman uh blaming them
is really it's so disingenuous it's so
it's so unfair and it's just it's just
avoids the reality of what's going on in
america today
yeah my favorite part of that tweet was
at the end when he said and just do it
now
who does he think he's talking to and
who does he think he is
this is a free economy the economy
responds to market impulses it should
never respond to a president's tweet
just do it now but you know most of
those gas stations janine they're
they're
immigrants a lot of them are first
generation americans who are hustling
who are busting it trying to make a
living in the united states of america
they don't have massive profit margins
they are trying to just be entrepreneurs
on the local level god bless them that's
a part of the spirit of america i agree
and liberals and especially progressives
have never understood that's that
individual initiative that individual
innovator that get up early go to bed
late work all day
immigrant dolphin who makes america work
you're right about that you know was
something new that we're seeing now
kellyanne is homelessness as a result of
inflation people who are losing their
homes are not able to make rent
are now finding themselves homeless
because of this consistent rise in food
gas prices and they're just not being
able to meet their bills
i never thought we'd see homelessness
based upon the inability of people who
had jobs now not being able to even keep
up with their own standard of living
that's the vexing fact of joe biden is
america judge you have people who have a
job two three jobs in the household and
they say the job's not even enough they
can't meet basic expenses and that
washington post article that you're
referring to was quite compelling today
people should read it for this reason
talks to a woman who made one hundred
thousand dollars last year this year she
fell behind on her rent her family has
been living in their hyundai and
showering at the gym and living with
different you know trying to get meals
from different family members they
actually these are now job holders
before if you lost your job you had a
medical emergency
or something else that was really a big
bill you weren't expecting maybe you'd
fall behind in your rent but the
homelessness now is uh up among single
moms 15 states say they've seen an
increase and their wait lists are
doubling
and tripling so these decisions by joe
biden have consequences and look his
approval rating is the lowest now of
obama's trump's or his at this point
before the midterm election why is that
relevant joe biden's probably looking
around saying how did this happen how is
mine low quick answer you earned it you
earned every low approval rating and now
he should be made to eat it along with
the democrats because people
are suffering but folks it's people who
had homes and and rented or owned homes
and had jobs not so long ago now
homeless well and you know ari i think
kellyanne is is right i mean he not only
owns it but i think people realize it
which is why the number 36
his approval rating and 88 of the
country thinks we're going in the wrong
direction i mean they are pointing the
finger at joe aren't they ari
and there's not only republicans of
course or independents who are doing it
but if you're a democrat you have to
scratch your head and say what has joe
biden done for me since he became
president there are only two things i
can think of one is unemployment remains
low i don't know that joe biden deserves
a credit but it still is happening on
his watch number two is he's not mean
tweeting and i think that's for a lot of
democrats comfort he might be foolish
tweeting but he's not mean tweeting
interesting i think that's only things
that democrats can point to they
certainly can't point to the economy
it's in terrible shape they can't point
to inflation it's going through the roof
once again for the first time in 40
years they can't point to law and order
they can't point to crime they can't
point to the border they can't point to
the withdrawal from afghanistan
everything joe biden has done has had
the reverse midas touch
everything he has done he has messed up
wow so if you're a democrat you've got
to really say to yourself is he the best
we can do can we can we do better than
an 80 year old
candidate after this midterm to lead our
party into the 2024 election and they're
increasingly leading the way saying no
he can't that is going to burst into
open the day after the election no doubt
about it kellyanne conway ari fleischer
thanks so much for being with us tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else